قال وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان صويلو
الى تركيا تواجه الكارثه الاكبر في
تاريخها لكنها تبذل اقصى جهودها لتجاوزها
اضاف الوزير في مؤتمر صحفيا في كهرمان
مارش انه تم دفن 600 شخص في المنطقه وان
العمليه ستستمر بعد عمليه التوثيق
رغم ان تركيا خبرت الكثير من الكوارث قبل
الان على شكل زلازل وحرائق وغيرها الا
اننا ربما نواجه الكارثه الكبرى في تاريخ
تركيا بسبب اتساع مساحه الدمار حيث انهار
نحو 941 مبنا في كهرمان مراش لوحدها
انهيار تاما عدا عن المباني المتضرره
جزئيا او تلك التي انهار جزء منها فقط
نركز جهودنا على انقاذ المواطنين من تحت
الانقاض قبل كل شيء حتى الان تم دفن 600
مواطن في كهرمان مراش بعد التعرف على
جثامنهم من قبل الاقارب وتوثيقها واخذ
بصماتهم وما زالت عمليات الدفن مستمره